[Música]
si son rosas en tu infancia te vestirán
de tu color
deberá jugar a juegos como la mamá la
cocina la caja registradora no pueden
gustarte los juegos de los azules como
por ejemplo los autos
cuando crezcas deberás dejar tu pelo
largo vestir ropa ajustada
sentarte con las piernas cruzadas nunca
decir malas palabras y tu tono de voz
deberá ser dulce siempre
quiero contar una historia la historia
de como yo sobreviví mi adolescencia
entre el rosa y el azul
es una historia que he decido contarla
porque sé que tal vez no haya podido
estar acá para hacerlo y sé que hay
muchas historias como la mía que no
pudieron ser escuchadas porque esas
personas ya no están
mi infancia fue relativamente como la de
todos hasta aproximadamente 11 años
excepto algunas cosas que me hacían
ruido como por ejemplo en la primaria
cuando tenía que usar el uniforme de
gimnasia color rojo aunque los varones
usaban el color azul y el azul siempre
fue mi color preferido
en los primeros años de secundaria
cuando eso quería hacer gimnasia con mi
mejor amigo y no podía porque las
mujeres por un lado y los hombres por
otro
comencé a sentirme más cómoda cuando
utilizaba la ropa de mi hermano
para mí era súper normal pero la gente
de mi edad se burlaba de mí en la casa
le señalaban
esto genera una confusión en mí una
confusión que desde ese día no hizo más
que empeorar
mi vida comenzó a caer en picada cuando
me di cuenta que me gustaba una amiga
creí que era buena idea contárselo a mi
mamá desde un psicólogo
quieres decirme que esto sólo era una
etapa empeoró mi confusión
recuerdo que ese día por primera vez
cuando llegué a mi casa me cuestioné mi
género
a mí no me molesta ocultar esto pero en
el colegio estaban empezando a correr
rumores la gente se estaba empezando a
enterar
como no quería que nadie se enterara por
todo lo que estaba pasando decidí
aislarme a mis compañeros
me encerré tanto en mis propios
pensamientos que lanzarme
comenzaron a darme pastillas
que lejos de ayudar me tenían adormecida
todo el día
y que pudo haber pasado todo el colegio
se enteró de que esos hallaban una chica
se empezaron a burlar de mí se empezaron
a burlar de mi hermano
como no quería ocasionarle problemas a
nadie me cambia de colegio me cambiaron
de colegio dos veces en ninguno puede
encajar
yo no podía explicar la raíz de mis
problemas porque no los entendía ni
siquiera eso misma
un día cansada de estar adormecida por
las pastillas
a darle un referente de precios y me los
tomé hasta que no quedó ninguno
desde que nacemos esta sociedad nos
impone reglas a seguir los clasifican en
rosas y azules no existen las colores y
no podemos elegir con el que nos
sintamos cómodos
muchas personas todos los días sufren
por no poder seguir estas reglas
estudios realizados por deterioro en
eeuu aseguran que las personas
pertenecientes al colectivo lgtb de iq
si las que significan lesbianas gays
bisexuales e intersexuales y queers
son cuatro veces más propensos al
suicidio
además de que el 90% de los estudiantes
pertenecientes en este colectivo
sufren de acoso escolar
y que cada 19 horas una persona
perteneciente del colectivo es asesinada
o agredida físicamente
debemos continuar informando que existe
una infinidad de colores más allá que el
rosa y el azul y que no importa el color
con el que la persona que tenemos al
lado se identifique todos merecemos
respeto y compresión por igual gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]
i